Il y a tant de choses à dire. Il
y a tellement de cause qui sont
enjeux. Quelles so
principales menaces auxquelles
font face nos océae nos océans?
passer sur ses menaces.
Aujourd'hui, on parlait du
plastique à Lisbonne et demain
On parle d'acidification des
de la mer avec les érosions
côtières, manque d'oxygène dans
les océans et les pactes que ça
mais aussi des aires marines
protégées, de solutions de
comment peut protéger tout ça eu
inefficaces à leur actuelle au
niveau global pour pouvoir faire
du développement durable etla pé
des océans pour les générati
futures.
- On ne sait pas reprendre le
la question du plastique, c'est
un des aspects les plus
médiatisés, bien sûr, je ne sais
pas c'est la menace la plus
fait? Ça va tripler, dans les
prochaines années, dit-on.temene
l'équivalent d'un camion à
ordures chaque minute en
plastique dans les océans, donc
ces majeurs et mal
efforts qui sont faits pour
faire des nettoyages il y a
finaux au Canada pour essayer de
contrer ution
plastique, le problème, c'est
qu'on en émet encore beaucoup et
produit depuis l'invention de
cette matière exi, car
ça se dégrade très lentement,
sinon pas du tout. Donc, la
dans nosdans nosdans nosdans nos
impact évidemment tous lesanimar
nous revenir un peu en plein
visage, parce que c'est les
remplis de plastique. Les
dernières études montrent que le
micro plastique, il y en a d
Margaux dans l'eau du robinet,
l'eau en bouteille, dans les
huîtres, dans les poissons et
penser que c'est juste le
problème de la pauvre petitetore
plastique. C'est aussi un
problème de santé humaine, comme
Saturne pérennité en tant
qu'humain.
- Il y a notre espèce, mais les
écosystèmes sont éminemment
principaux impacts de cette
dégradatqu'onqu'onqu'onqu'onqu'n
l'observe en ce moment? de sants
écosystèmes, au sens large, est
présentement mises Par l'état de
santé des océans. Et ces
plusieurs produits et services,n
environ 15 % de toutes les
protéine consommées
sur terre qui vienne de la mère.
C'est vrai pour le tourisme,
chaque année par des écosystèmes
C'est vrai pour le rôle qu'elles
ont dans le ralentissement
leur capacité de capter une
partie de nos gaz e
serre. Donc, la santé des
océans, est étroitement
lié.
- Quand on parle des changements
climatique. Vous venez de parler
d'exempl qui nous renvoie à des
pratiques bien enrt
encore temps pour inverser la
tendanceue,
comme disait Monsieur Gutiérrez?
- Il est encore temps, et danset
intéressant, c'est qu'on n'a pas
de le luxe de se passer de
savoir de personne. Ce qui est
discuté au sommet de Lisbonne
cette semaine, c'est ces
partenariats et cette
En utilisant le savoir où des
scientifiques, mais le savoir
lequel acet
océan ou de cet océan.
Et je pense que dans un état
d'urgence, que ce soit
d'urgence de santé, d'un
écosystème un ton départ, on n'a
pas le luxe de se passer des
connaissances de personnes.
Et on le sent vraiment à
travailler ensemble pour trouver
les meilleures sol
possibles.
- Tout parlons de la
situation du Canada comme tel,
r trois ocr trois ocr trois ocr.
Ou est-ce qu'on se situe dansso,
pour inverser la tendance?- Je n
isolé ou protégé sous une cloche
de verre. Les gran
face, à l'échelle globale, ce
sont lesification, la
pollution plastique, tout ce qus
petite échelle, celle du pays,
ce sont les mêmes enjeux.
la délégation des vins quelques
nations qui sont p
Lisbonne pour discuter de
solutions solutions solutions ss
pour le plastique, pour essayer
de freiner le changements
ir. C'est ir. C'est ir. C'est is
important chez nous parce qu'ons
climatiques se font ressentir
trois fois plus rapidement danùa
planète. On a des océans
fragiles, des options qui sont
des ressources au niveau des
pêcheries, donc la volonté est
là et l'importan
protégeait. C'est crucial..
- Et c'est l'effort de
i doit être
déployée pour que la populationa
situation. Dans quelle mesure
des rencontres comme celle-ci
peuvent entraîner et peuvent
contribuer à atteindre ses
objectifs?
Que les
l'on ne peut plus prendre les
océans pour acquis, encore une
fois, pour citer António
Guterres.
- On a longtemps prie les océans
pour OK, où ce genre de
conférence à se parler de
l'importance de l'océan pour la
santé humaine. Mais au-delà de
ça, il faut qu'après, après la
réunion qui dure une semaine
gallo-romaine finaux avec une
réelle volonté de changer les
choses et de le faire une
différen
plus compliquée, c'est que les
enjeux sont tellement gros que
souvent c'est facile de se
sentir impuissant devant
l'ampleur de ces enjeux et del e
façon d'aborder les problèmes
présentement qui est dépassé par
l'inspiration et l'optimiste en
prenant pour exempl les
entrepôts où ils ont réussi à
faire des pas de g
protection des océans , en
s'inspirant de ce premier les
mêmes C'est
vrai entre autres au niveau des
armes à Rennes protégeait en
Australie, ce sont les pionniers
de mise en place d'art protégé.e
du travail à faire. J'ose
espérer que d'ici 2030,
l'objectif est d'avoir 30 %d'art
partout sur la planète.
Notre pays fait partie des
signataires de cet objectif. Il
faut s'inspirer de
ça fonctionne, et c'est par la
même chose d'abord par des
enjeux qui sont énormes.
- Pour ne pas sombrer dans le
cynisme de le désespoir, le
fatalisme et tout le reste.
On s'accroche à ses initiat